Spirit of Italy starting in February at
the carnavale Extravaganza at Italy Las
Vegas and here to kick it off we have
general manager Luca Esposito Lucas so
great to see you great to see you too
thanks for bringing us A Taste of Italy
to ourselves here and let's talk about
what you guys have planned for February
February is going to be a great month
and I am personally so excited about it
there's so many things going on and we
really decided to focus on Carnevale
which historically it's considered to be
this last moment of fun and craziness
before the restrictions of Lent and so
we chose the first two weeks to
celebrate to start from February 1 to
February 11th we're going to celebrate
restroom Fest which I personally love
because it's two quarts 29 125 cocktail
is 16 and it's an accessible way to come
and enjoy Italy and the way we do things
at Italy and then we're going to have
been a week which is going to be 40
selected of venator wines that's a great
deal exactly and straight to the action
for every 11th with the Festa Carnival
Extravaganza you can purchase your
tickets online on italy.com on the Las
Vegas city and events or the linking bio
on our Instagram account and Vino day
this is going to be even better 40 on 4
plus any wine so this is the moment to
stock up your house yes absolutely that
is a great deal and I love when you walk
into Italy you truly feel like you are
just transported into Italy exactly you
don't have to leave Las Vegas to
experience it and it's also a great
place to celebrate maybe Valentine's Day
or date night right correct we have so
many things going on I brought a little
heart here of chocolate we're gonna have
heart-shaped desserts some of our
restaurants are going to be heart-shaped
pizza and also at Toscana restaurant and
bar by Italy you're going to have a
prefix menu for all couples that sounds
delicious I always love a heart-shaped
pizza too it's a perfect way to just get
in the spirit you guys have so much
going on and I love that Italy is so
centrally located whether you're going
in or you know before a concert or after
a night's game we're going to make a
whole night out of it you guys exactly
it is this moment of embracing quality
food Italian way uh if you're a
cochinder Mercado if you're a la Pizza
La Pasta or Toscana there's an option
for everyone well Luca thank you so much
for being here cheers to everything you
have going on I'll be in for some of
that wine be sure to stop by Italy they
have so much great stuff going